this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
that's right what's up buddy not much
back at it pal back at it always back at
it been doing it a long time Brennan ups
and downs you know what I mean as we
look at each other and our backs are a
little bowed other times our backs are
straight our chests are out it's the
nature of how it goes bro it's the
nature of how everything goes Circle of
Life the clouds come in and block the
sunshine clouds leave and the Sunshine
starts hitting you again the frustrating
thing about being a human being is this
I'm going to give you this I'm gonna
give you this as an older man but give
me the difference between here we go a
liberal mindset and a conservative oh
God although we're kicking this off with
them servant of mine said says that you
are you are flawed as a human being from
the start always will be human nature is
human nature you're not better than your
ancestors you're just just under
different circumstances and anytime you
hear anybody out there telling you that
we can perfect society and perfect you
as a person run the other way
so with that I'd like to just sing a
song please
I'm a conservative and American that
doesn't mean I want to trample on your
social rights I believe in gay marriage
but I also own a gun
and I'd like to ride a horse with the
American flag hoisted high with a dinner
on the back if that's what it means as
long as they're an adult and they made
their own choice I support it
keep away from my kids
that's been me
Kenny Chesney not bad thanks bud not bad
at all
I don't know right I've been through
this sandals on sandals you've been
watching anything lately today what's
that of course dude you've been watching
anything lately
you know I have I'm watching on that
plane ride you gotta stock up on some
Netflix I I watched a classic movie
called Breakfast Club you ever see that
yeah man shed a tear yeah watch anything
current new I'm watching I hit you I'm
watching Tehran
which is that with Arnold
no it's on Apple TV and it's about
Israeli the Israeli Mossad and how they
infiltrate Iran's nuclear oh that's cool
facilities and it's it is it is
it it looks like it's as real as it can
get there's two there's another show
called The Bureau if you ever want to
see how smart intelligence agencies are
no you're good
do what hey do you watch anything
anybody else watches or hey should I
start talking about the tax code
uh do I watch anything I don't you don't
watch Black Mirror or nothing
with that have you I I've it scares me
and depresses me because it's so it's
usually depressing and I I watched
season one and two and I just whatever
the one about the dog yeah I watched
season one and two and I fell off three
four five and then six Delia was talking
about it and then when I was traveling
uh last week I was like I need something
to watch I'll just download the whole
series only six episodes damn is it good
this one's not it's so good I can't too
depressing this one's not dude it's the
liability of what technology will do
right like yeah they have one episode
where it's like it's it's called I think
strawberry stream and it's in that world
it's their version of Netflix and it has
this device that tracks in real time
like it follows your life whatever
through a phone or cameras you can't
figure it out and it this this lady
she's they use AI to tell her story like
literally the next day she doesn't know
how they're getting it and she's she's
not a bad person but when you exaggerate
it makes her seem terrible so I think
it's called Joan is awful her name's
Joan so it's like she fires this girl
but she was pretty cool about it but
then exaggerates it in her it's like a
reality series exaggerates it and some
will hike plays her but it's AI
so it's just and it just ruins her life
do you remember the one where they could
read your mind they could like tune into
what you had just seen yeah just like
with a computer yeah like you are a
recording device yeah you think I'm
weird it's some weird [__] I mean please
understand please [__] understand
that when you're walking down the street
your your conversation is being recorded
by the ring cameras of every door you
pass
yeah it's not yeah it is yeah so you're
saying [__] and people it's it is being
logged in their phone in their home and
then also with with your phone though
yeah cia's listening Everything 100
they're probably laughing on our group
texts the Shop's another dick pic or
whatever well I talked to a Google
engineer and said we have so many
firewalls I go you guys are reading our
emails they go you're out of your
[__] mind he goes do you know how how
many safeguards they're out of that like
if you even whiff of that like you're in
trouble it's like I don't know how you
but of course he says that no but he was
we were told they're for sure reading
our stuff I mean it's been out this has
been outed yeah they want to read it
they could but they'd get in big trouble
yeah oh no like or what trouble well you
know by who well you know the the
judicial system is definitely affecting
elections according to Robert Epstein
yeah there's a ton of that out there
yeah there's a ton that out there
there's one where there's two guys like
they're normal they're humans real
humans and they're in space I don't know
what mission they're going to do but
they need each other and then on Earth
they came up with a some sort of
technology where it's their exact same
bodies but they're robots we can't tell
but they have family yeah
this is Black Mirror dude
my girl didn't like that stuff and I
thought I'm like you just gotta watch it
and this is on Sunday the kids are
outside like just watch one while I'm
outside and then she was in all he's
doing is she's taking technology as they
say and then extrapolating where it's
going to be in 20 years but the
technology they can't only get away with
so many episodes then there's one where
this kid goes back to his hometown in
like Ireland and he wants to do this
documentary on that there was this like
killing going on there and that that
one's one of the best there's another
one where it's always written by one guy
too it was so [__] so there's another
one where there's this famous actress
and um like the paparazzi catches she
accidentally kills a guy she don't know
how to deal with it so she hires that
she has to go into rehab she hires like
a dark arts rehab guy I'll leave it at
that dude there's another one where this
this guy comes he comes in the form of a
demon but then she gets all scared so
he's and it's he's British they're in
England she's the Indian woman and she
works at a shoe store and this demon
comes to her because she grabs like
whatever some you know haunted thing of
course that opens up the portal he comes
he scares [__] he's like oh but he's
funny he's like love I didn't mean to
scare you oh I forgot you guys don't
like this so he switches identity to
like the 70s dancer but he's like here's
the deal you have to kill three people
in the next 48 hours but they have to be
bad people it can't just be you know
innocent people you gotta kill three bad
people you can pick whoever you want you
gotta kill three if you don't it's
Armageddon she's like you're crazy
whatever but he's like all right she's a
really nice person but don't tell me I'm
not gonna tell you but oh it's dope
she's a really nice person you'd be like
asking to kill somebody like I can't do
that yeah but he's like oh you can't
really and there's a guy walking down
the street goes look at this and she he
can see the future and he's molesting
his daughter he's like and she commits
suicide at 28. so if you don't kill him
yeah yeah so he like helps oh listen
there are plenty of people that I would
kill like I've always had this fantasy
of being able to see where all the child
molesters or serial killers are like
like I have a special Vision that those
people I would kill and sleep so well
the pedophiles I would easily yeah but
all day just there are so many bad
people
I mean there are some bad [__] people
out there but think if you could somehow
realize that and then go after him he's
in the law you'd end up in jail you
can't get away with killing anybody we
live in a surveillance uh you can get
away with it for sure you're in a
surveillance statement it doesn't a lot
of people get with it all the time
you're always I think I think the murder
rate of getting caught's like 50 find
out because we're always on camera
because South South Chicago says hold my
bear that's true people die all the time
we're always in we're always on camera
about half
yeah it's about 50 buddy unsolved some
without clearance so oh it's about a
half you have a 50 shot
if I'm playing Blackjack I'm I'm All In
man I kill you right now dude and 50
odds that's crazy you could you didn't
know that right did you know that tune
50 I have no idea you you couldn't kill
me I keep a knife on me yeah but if I
did I have a 50 chance of getting away
with it yeah but I could also do this
but oh isn't that crazy though yeah I
think it was that crazy yeah 50 that's
insane I'm very I'm amazed and then
here's the other thing in say California
in New York if you do get caught
get your answer I ain't going away for
about four years might make bail
not the end of the world you asked me
we're headed towards the purge well
stock up
wouldn't that be weird if they did The
Purge
how ready are you for the purge not
really I have guns for days have you
seen my house 14 foot walls
good luck you're [__] yeah my [__] is
a fortress huh I'll come over yeah you
need you need somebody to go and
everything and mine's up like this like
my whole house you need friends who can
guard like all all windows and all sides
you can't just be on your own well did
you ever watch The Purge actual movie
that guy sells those security systems
that like lock all the windows that's
what you need yep
it's always weigh-in it's a stupid
concept one day and just gets all the
aggression out now I mean no no that's
not the way killers work either no
one setting it all up anyway I'd have a
sniper's nest you'd have to you know
the way you uh the way I uh they do it
snipers will do it is they'll be in a so
there's a room and then they'll be in
the a room behind that and they have the
window open
so now they're they're shooting you from
two rooms deep in a house
and they just find a beat pop catch you
right there yeah yes we have a down with
a sniper where the [__] did that come
from
I wonder if that dude from uh
the Wagner group they're saying he's in
hiding I'm very I was watching curious
about this do you see what Putin said
he said he's under investigation oh no
no Putin's thing was vile earlier today
which would be last night go ahead and
bring that up violent oh oh why you
don't think trees and Traders you think
Putin is gonna it's gonna oh then did
you hear what he said about North
America
he was ran by by a satanic cult
it's not far from yeah
some of the stuff he said about America
you're like all right well
well there you go Putin orders probe
into Wagner's Chief Joe Warren Chief's
finances as Wagner leader arrives in
Belarus
okay
there's no way do you think they're
gonna find uh something on them there or
there's no way that guy stays alive I
what do you give them
I give them two weeks well that's what
that that General goes I'll give him 60
to 90 days no he's being more generous
to me I give him two weeks
despite the loss he's everything
including the fact that they went to
criminal Acts
to spit split and weaken the country
which is now he's had some Botox huh
colossal external threat he's got a lot
of bowties
it can be tough enough Botox right who's
the toughest guy with botox maybe boom
uh they're they're all relatives
dictators in our super vain Gaddafi
Gaddafi is the most Gaddafi horrible
human being the most lit outfits dude
you do seven outfits 100 and the dopest
sunglasses he might have been a little
gay 100 when I was watching this
documentary oh he's a gay man right
seven outfit changes and it wasn't like
suits he was like Hey like very vibrant
Gaddafi's vibrant clothing
thank you I was gonna ask you qua d d a
f i I need you I'm gonna need you to
spend more time
10. no it's just names I can spell
everything else but people's names
Gaddafi also got a lot of surgery on his
face well when he was younger he was
much more handsome and I can tell you
lid surgery right there you guys have
similar faces but he uh he had a lot of
stuff done he's so who you would be
look if I was a dictator oh dude lit
dude oh Bro Look at that [__] what are
we talking about hold on bring up can I
see individual shots here this is
beautiful
what's going on you guys know much about
Gaddafi insane dude oh he was he he was
actually the leader of Libya and unlike
other he started out pretty hard he
didn't he didn't Purge people
not at first but he was uh you can't
have a horrible human being
well he was a product of that but if you
go back to him his outfits were lit look
at him go down to him where he's in the
brown suit that's him younger who's kind
of a diamond oh handsome guy yeah don't
kid yourself you don't think he's a
handsome guy there he's a leader of a
country handsome [__] dude First Team
all style that's first dictators nobody
better nobody better this is not as a
hot take care best uh military outfits
of all time these some dark people here
there's I'd say they're three right the
Russians back in the day when Stalin lit
outfits I don't think so I I don't mind
them bring that up chin but they were
number one was the Nazi Hugo Boss
designed him Nazis had by far the best
uniforms yeah don't condone what they
did no lit outfits then Gaddafi as far
as dictators go no no there's no doubt
oh well so name another one so bring up
Saddam Hussein and so with Saddam
Hussein they always said people have
followed this Saddam Hussein would uh do
you know who he is yeah man holy [__]
you want this fashion or what do you
want yeah yeah uh Saddam Hussein so with
Osama saying every five years or so or
even three years all the people around
him would be they'd just disappear oh he
he had anxiety you didn't trust anybody
killed his brother-in-law yes and then
he they'd all be purged and then you'd
see a new group of people with Gaddafi
he kept the same people around him for
20 years that's the move so he was never
he wasn't into purges wait now now
looking at him apparently he was in
shape I just heard that I told you that
when they caught him yeah the guy who
caught him was like surprisingly the
dude was he was fit yes he was fit oh
[__]
son
am's outfit's pretty good good Off You
by far number one
there's another Pig old one don't know
how real these are but they're real okay
you know what the number you know what
the thing he hated most I was reading
this article so there's this there's
this young kid and when they when they
caught Saddam right they they before he
went on trail and was hung and murdered
right uh well executed he was held for
like six months and they put some young
kid from like North Carolina his first
mission he flies over there they don't
he doesn't know what he's doing it
doesn't really want to go and they go
hey we got a gig for you you and your
friends it was him and his five buddies
you're gonna watch over Saddam Hussein
and he's like so we got to know him he's
actually a really nice guy he was like
what was crazy is we would see he'd be
in a cell and he goes and we'd have to
sit there for hours and see you're
talking to him that's what he said and
he was really nice and polite he
absolutely loved uh Doritos he loved
Doritos they said he'd get a bag of
Doritos and finish them in minutes love
Doritos the thing he hated the most
Fruit Loops he wouldn't eat they'd go
hey dude we're all at the chow hall
we're all all we have today is Fruit
Loops he's like I'd rather not eat
despise Fruit Loops despise Fruit Loops
and then he how was his English good his
English was good and they said he
obviously he's wicked smart smart dude
don't get it twisted Wicked smart I mean
you and I are partying you and I are
guarding Saddam Hussein okay
oh I'm telling you after day two I'm
like we gotta get him I'll be we gotta
we gotta we gotta figure out how to get
this this guy is a savant well you and I
would definitely pick his brain about
all things about everything he was great
they said the only time he ever got
emotional was talking about his
daughters he's like I was a good dad
that's one thing he can't do I was a
good dad like he loved his daughters
that's the only time they say you'd cry
because he cried about not seeing his
daughters his daughters were sending
mail still they're still alive by the
way yeah I'm sure uh and the mother they
would send a mail and then he um yeah
they just said he was like a guy's guy
and then he would talk to all the guys
and be like any women out there for you
guys and then he just talk about like
he's like motion like [__] all the
time yeah
he was he knew you know that's a guy so
you see the the lady in the blonde up
top there yeah
that might be his daughter but the so
his original wife who has kids with he
met this dying piece
met this Dime Piece was like oh I like
her and literally the wife found out
from like his sure it was like okay you
got a divorce from me she's like what
yeah he moved on this blonde
so mistress send out so his brother his
two sons if you see Uday who's very tall
and kusei Uday was a psychopath Uday was
a social yeah he was a total terrible on
torturing people he who say was more um
quiet about it he ran he was smarter he
was smarter in control yeah and he was
actually helping his dad yeah who day
this is how bad of a person he was he
saw a wedding going on and he literally
stopped he used to it all the time and
killed everybody and raped the brother
he used to rape he would take them he'd
rape the bride he was into that he was
in a just psycho just a real sociopath
yeah psycho [__] and said I'm hate him
for that because he's a liability he
hated it well Saddam had him arrested
and beaten up oh he put He put him in
jail for him he had different people
from the Republican guards and they wore
masks because they knew who they would
get revenge on him
what a weird thing
what a weird [__] world man
who is his hero Stalin that's right he
had a whole Library everyone left Stalin
he dressed Hitler's hero is Stalin well
no Hitler they were boys and then he
[__] them over yeah they were they
were uh but he looked up to Stalin
everyone looked up to Stalin said I'm
saying him well when you're a guy who
kills 40 million people without batting
an eye like look at you yeah I mean
you're the Cal Ripken of dictator and he
he was a he was a hardcore communist who
said you know this person just doesn't
quite believe enough in the mission so
we're gonna get rid of him and he would
he'd say stuff like this he'd go kill
his wife in front of him first
it's because he needs to know and then
kill him yeah
he had different people that would run
all the Death the the death stuff Baria
was the last guy and he was
horrible
horrible yeah but Gaddafi most lit
dictator of all time as far as outfits
yeah straight up hypebeast yeah
it's here not so much interesting that
to guard Saddam Hussein
wow that's what they the the young guys
were saying they're like it's weird
because we know you did all these
horrible crimes yeah but then you see
the man in front of you and he's talking
to you and it's well he makes it human
you're like oh he's just he's a human
he's just like us yes obviously has that
terrible side it happens with serial
killers like even when Ted Bund not Ted
Bundy he was a piece of [__] but with uh
he's very Charming uh Jeffrey Dahmer
though like the the the hidden tapes
like the lady was like you sit down like
yo he's just like you can see like he
used to be a you it was a child one time
yeah he starts talking and Jeffrey Don
remember he was the first one like yep
did everything let me tell you how you
did it let me tell you who they were and
then you hear him talking they're like
whatever victim 14 like do you remember
her name's like I don't that's what
pisses people off because he's like oh
did you ever hear him
like how [__] up is that if that was
like your daughter he's like Ted was
like Mary Samantha they're all Becky's
like that's right Becky I cut her head
off you know what the [__] Ted Bundy was
a guy who used to he said he articulated
it there's a video of it he said I I
would uh I would kill I would have this
overwhelming need to kill I would do it
and I get this tremendous remorse I
should get this to me then buddy never
no Ted bunny never admitted it Ted bunny
the only way they got him later on no he
never did no the only way that me clear
it up to him the only way he would talk
about it is in as in third person as if
he knew the guy oh that's what [__]
him so they they said he was such a
narcissist and he thought he's smarter
than everybody and he was wicked smart
he he was his own lawyer he was a smart
smart [__] dude he was his own lawyer
during the trial and the judge goes you
know what's a shame is you've been
mowing the best damn lawyers I've ever
seen if you did if you went down that
path and not this other path
sick compulsion he had he had some but
the only way then that scares the
detective get him to talk is like hey if
this person did that no if this person
did this how would they go about doing
it and then he filled in all the holes
wow
even when they went on death row they're
like you want to say anything he's like
[__] you are you sure yeah man look that
up Ted bunny never admitted to
he would only talk about in the third
person you guys are both wearing a
couple skull caps huh
skullcap boys I feel like a mini
evolution of chin
you're getting there after more than a
decade of denials he invested 30 murders
commitment and they think it's over 30.
they think it's more like 70. you
confessed to him so he did actually
confess
look at how psycho he was oh you go to
it said did did Ted bunny ever actually
confess go to that you don't use Google
do we [__] soy boys Jesus Christ
you should Mark down
[Music]
let's go do you actually convince
yeah he's got around that yellow bus VW
keep going down oh yeah he escaped out
of Salt Lake City prison way to go and
then you went on a killing spree keep
going
spree continued oh here we go last
minute confession
tip I believe that if he confesses
crimes Accords with postpone his
execution by confessing bunny figured
that the Florida governor would allow
bunny to live so that he could be used
as a tool to locate the body some of the
missing victims but Bundy was wrong his
appeals were all used up the governor's
office ignored Bunny's request for a
stay of execution
36 wins and the days prior to his death
bunny finally confessed to the chilling
murders of 36 women they think it's 70
by the way the murders took place across
multiple States
most are young women some as young as 12
Jesus what
their investors believe that bunny could
have been responsible for the deaths up
to 100 women but with the man the media
Deb The Co-Ed Killer now dead for over
three years high on like that the world
will ever know exactly how many killed
so literally right before he was sent to
death but when they originally caught
him the only way they could film the
holes is by him talking about well this
is how the guy's doing it and like oh
it's clearly him geez
isn't that crazy that was new for
investigators they they hadn't really
looked into the mind of a complete
psycho like that no not until created
the behavioral sciences Department of
the FBI right yeah uh Johnny Douglas the
one who turned coined the term serial
killer before there's never a term for
it the FBI the John E Douglas he's great
I wish we could get him on the Pod he
writes all the serial killer books my
favorite books contact with them I know
we were years ago I can get him on his
son uh does all his bookings
because he wasn't traveling to the
pandemic he'd be great I have a
connection but you know that the show
mind hunter that that's written off him
that's all him so so you know the you
know the smart guy the weird smart guy
that's Kemper yeah no Ed Kemper is a
serial killer the actual detective you
know the younger one yeah that's based
off John Douglas oh okay that's it
you're fascinated with serial killing
yeah I love it too much I know all about
it I don't know that show was supposed
to keep going then uh something happened
yeah I heard they were gonna bring it
back but I think it's like Charles
Manson my guess is it's a little bit
like uh the way an alcoholic can't stop
drinking they maybe have a wire crossed
where they just can't stop killing
no
I don't know because Ted bunny killed
I'm sorry Jeffrey Dahmer killed when he
was 18 and took like nine years off yeah
and then and then once then it was just
on then he's like [__] it
yeah he killed a Dharma killed men right
gay men only gay men yeah only gay men
and ate them right yeah after
after yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah Dahmer's a weird one
do you know but boy was he lit though
like he he once they caught him he's
like all right what do you want to know
they're like how about the guy who
killed that woman that reporter in a
submarine
remember that guy yeah and then try to
get away with it yeah
those one-offs or whatever though the
serial killer is what I'm all about you
know
yeah do you know Ed Kemper voiced like
he did the the audiobook for the Star
Wars books I didn't know that Ed Kemper
did so Ed Kemper you know Ed Camp Ed
kemper's IQ was higher than Einstein's
oh do you know that b Ed kemper's iq's
nuts up legit genius yeah legit genius
no six eight six eight 330 pounds right
so enjoy getting away from that yeah
also Wicked smart he was so smart he'd
pull up because his co-ed murders uh in
Santa Barbara what's interesting about
him
is he was so smart even when there was
banners Flyers everywhere saying there's
a koi killer do not hitchhike girls are
still hitchhiking and he knew that was
going on so he'd pull up and go you need
a ride and he goes where are you going
they go whatever I'm going to Ojai he'd
look at his watch to confuse him go God
I got a meeting I I don't know if I'm
gonna have time and they said that would
lower their defenses because they'd be
like oh he's busy he probably can't give
me a ride like you know what I think I
make it go ahead and jump in
because first of all don't hitchhike
girls and don't get in the [__] car
with a white dude in his 30s or 40s or
50s or 20s well especially when there's
warnings all over campus saying what are
you doing girls
but you know how a house he caught
because his mom worked for the college
for the campus so he had this official
sticker for you know he did with his
employee
uh yeah I do Brian he well first of all
he cut her head off and then [__] her
mouth and throat that's right and he
ripped her throat out and [__] the
throat and then put in the disposal I
didn't know that part yeah see I didn't
know these details but I do know that
that was that was what he needed to heal
and turn himself in well his mom's part
of the problem right his mom was so mad
at her that when he did that he killed
he killed the ultimate feminine
archetype that was causing and then
[__] her throat after she ripped it
after he ripped it out of her neck yeah
that's an interesting that's that's a
hard thing to kind of put my wrap my
head around I just had a wonderful
conversation with my loving mother at 83
and I love her now remember he's also
six eight Brian yeah what dude
since I was eight let's play real quick
I'm not proud of that not many people
know that this famous serial killer
narrated the official Star Wars I didn't
know that what reaching for the internal
controls 3PO was shocked behave yourself
are too that man was Ed Kim what 10
people people in the night what are you
talking about who's California area and
was famously depicted in the Netflix
series dude him on Netflix series
whoever casted that deserves a [__]
Emmy volunteers well you know what that
would be a fascinating guy to be guarded
because he's well no he he helped a lot
well we know about Syracuse now a lot of
it's Ed Kemper really he helped out a
lot big time they would meet with him
all the time and he he'd give him info
like this is what he's going to do next
he's gonna go back to the site he's
probably masturbating at the last site
where he killed the person many
audiobooks in the 80s
play some football you [__] idiot
also dude also yeah Without Anger no not
basketball no he's white right but dude
as an outside [__] as a tackle you're
six eight three Thirty and wicked smart
do you hate money yet and you have all
that aggression take that aggression out
on the defense because he wanted to take
it out on women yeah we're taking on the
defense
like Waterboy mad at girls what a boy he
was mad at his mom and they said
apparently when he after he did that to
his mom he was like ah finally yeah I
have the impulse anymore and he went and
turned himself into the cops he shut her
up but but yeah but then he he also he's
he Ed Kemper is [__] fascinating
because he also did not get caught he
would there's a local bar it's still
there I've been to it in Santa Barbara
where all the cops hang out he would go
there all the time he became chummy with
the cops so they they'd get done with
their shift and all the cops hang out
there and like what's up good while the
investigation's going on he's like you
believe this this is insane man and they
were like oh well I never suspect that's
what that book I read where where the
guy was giving a lecture on cereal only
caught the social path on the ground
well yeah there was a guy who they were
investigating as a serial killer who was
in the crowd and he but he said the
reason he was there is he wanted to
learn about himself he didn't know about
himself he didn't know why he had that
impulse he wanted to learn about himself
from City too are you crazy well that uh
that Idaho killer came like it was like
helping with the search and [__] after
he killed him
psychopath in him well it's power it's
like look what I did but he was also
that Idaho killer was also studying
become he had a criminal criminal
criminology yeah so he like thought he
could get dumb [__] also hey
oh and the cameras dude we got your car
dumbass is that not criminology
one-on-one I took several criminology
classes dude what are you doing dude
they say they say a knife typically
um nightmare would kill someone with a
knife so when when that guy that guy who
founded cash app he was killed by a
knife yes
um our boy Joseph who was a cop said he
said my guess is typically as a cop if
somebody gets knifed it's a personal
thing you knew the person 100 like they
they know you it's all personal because
the gun's not personal yeah there's no
emotion there you just pull the trigger
a nice very nice tricky because usually
when you're stabbing if they're doing a
lot it always the they always have scars
or there's something from the knife
always really nice dicey dude not dicey
dicey so if you don't see a lot of
serial killers killing with a knife so
when you get stabbed with a knife you're
supposed to if you can keep the knife in
your body yeah don't pull it out don't
pull it out but uh if you do get stabbed
and pulled out my friend who is a
special forces guy told me that um if
you don't get help if you don't get
immediate medical help you're gonna die
no even if it doesn't hit something
because if you lose barometric pressure
or something or you lose pressure in
your body sounds like bro sides right no
it's true if you get stabbed just I go
like that too once right in eight hours
you're gonna die well if you don't stop
it yeah well even if you stop the
bleeding
you're gonna stop bleeding from the
outside but still going yeah it's a
nightmare well you're a balloon no
matter who you are a knife is the great
equalizer you're a [__] balloon yeah
there's not a lot of circulos who use
knives
no it's just too dicey because because
when you're hitting the body the bone it
can Rick say off you cut your hand like
people have Cuts all the time look at OJ
use the knife
his hands were all [__] up
yeah I use a i groat people I use uh
piano wire that's been done before
very BTK killer of you yeah he was the
worst of the worst probably the best way
to die getting choked I don't think so
man better than stabbing you ever get
choked out in Jiu-Jitsu you go to sleep
you're like ah yeah but if that piano
wire would [__] It's Gonna Hurt
that's gonna hurt
that's gonna hurt real bad it's gonna
cut right through
yeah piano wire yeah you'd rather have
like a thick rope yeah
or you'd rather have nothing around your
throat that's also good
you know what I'm saying Bloody bulge
used to choke people today yep
because it's quiet
get personal very personal
we got dark on this one dude super dark
not too dark it's just serial killer
[__] just serial killer and they're all
caught
there's something like there's like 60
active serial killers right you if
you're a serial killer you you're strong
enough where you could like your whole
thing would be Twinkie men like real
delicate skinny men and you you would
just come up and get behind them and
squeeze them until they died and then
they would do that and then there'd be
no that's that that nobody would not
investigate that they'd be like he got
squeezed to death that doesn't make
sense broke all his ribs you wouldn't
even break his ribs you just hold them
until he can't breathe because when
Shane Collins squeezed me I couldn't
breathe yeah I would have died and and
like if you could do that if you're that
strong you could just squeeze until it
was in a workout well there's a smiley
face kills that we've been over with
that who are just drowning dudes yeah
but I feel like getting behind somebody
squeezing them It's So Silent they're
like this is what you hear
the thing about just drowning dudes in
that River in Austin just yeah
yeah but now you're getting scratched up
see you're getting scratched they're not
scratching back like this I do I go like
this uh and I get your your skin under
my nails you can't do it that way true
that would be true you can't do it you
have to um and plus you got to get
somebody down to the river oh come here
have you seen these fish I'm gonna be
like what look at these fish over here
no I don't what do you mean I assume
they're just going down oh you got to
put your head closer I assume they're
just going down there to take a piss in
the river
now you know I went to the Dead Sea
right that's up yeah with all the salt
so so the meta so so this is uh and
there's no there's no fish in there
either oh oh oh dude I got one for you I
didn't tell you about this so the the
Red Sea is supposed to be like I mean
the Dead Sea it's supposed to be so the
the sea in general I think the
Mediterranean Sea is what percentage
salt what would you say is percent so
Mediterranean just the normal ocean yeah
70.
three percent salt oh wow right man it's
okay hey man is this salty right is the
Pacific in the Atlantic three percent
yeah three percent my God right I know
holy [__] it's all the songs I thought
it was I was gonna thank you I was going
90 95 salt and that's me too like so
salty salty as [__] hurt you burns your
eyes oh my God right
three percent three percent four percent
and I hate Souls yeah dead sea salt on
food
37 sir that's all salt in the word but
that's why you float right oh that's why
you float so when you get in the water
you float literally this part of your
body doesn't get wet you can just lie in
there like that that's how you float
that's how you float right there now and
there's nothing that lives there right
uh no not at all now here's the thing I
don't know how he's that he's not that's
not the Dead Sea because I'd see a star
it is I think he's really fat that's
crazy because I see his stomach well
that's how big he is that's how you
float without him she took a gay picture
like that well so here's the problem
Brandon here's the problem couple issues
it's 37 salt now the first thing they
say is do not put your head under water
do not swallow the water or get it in
your ears and don't pee or we have to
take you to the hospital oh check please
now I licked it
I licked my hand and it burned the [__]
out of my tongue now I felt like a bat
like you're licking a battery yeah and
he goes if you have any cuts
you will
um you'll feel it you're going to
seizure well my my my my me and my son
I must have some fissures in my [__]
because my [__] started burning like
a [__] well I was just gonna say
do they tell you not to pee because that
in the pee hole I did so this is this is
where we get to I gotta pee I didn't
water I pee I took a piss I peed it I
jacked off on the floor huge mistake I
know you did was it burning bad my dick
was burning so bad I was like well I've
obviously got a venereal disease no
reason my dick should burn like this
more painful than that time you had
gonorrhea or by far really yeah
gonorrhea yes thank you see what I did
there um dude but I'm talking about I
looked at my wife I go I gotta get out
my dick is my dick and [__] are on
fire no no no no [__] that [__] the rest
I don't see I don't want to [__] all of
it and
hot hot is the water lukewarm it's so
warm my feet my feet burned you can't
walk down there without a nightmare [__]
yeah go to real ocean [__] off to all
the only good thing no sharks bad thing
your [__] is going to burn like crazy
your asshole's gonna burn like crazy now
the Sea of Galilee but isn't there
Christ walked on water that's a lake
that's fine yeah he walked on water We
Believe yeah and there's rails like
don't swim in it it's dirtier than you
think I was like enough said but is it
isn't there somewhere in uh Salt Lake
City too same thing in Utah oh those are
the Salt Flats but they're not actually
they don't have any water in them so
isn't there a place in Salt Lake City I
think so chin bring that up in Utah but
the dance so the Dead Sea is the lowest
point on Earth which I didn't know did I
think the Dead Sea was in Utah am I
[__] so just water with salt am I
[__] it's okay the Dead Sea is to
the two the two countries that border
the Dead Sea are the Great Salt Lake
yeah so that's 27 Brian that's pretty
high yeah that's a lake
27. that's impressive well that's the
level right now Bubba let me ask you
this but you but you can you can float
in that one
yeah I'm sure
we all float down here name the movie
one of the two countries that border the
dead name a movie think about it
oh yeah there it is see how that guy's
floating oh wow two countries Jordan is
that one yep
uh yeah you're right uh
there you go buddy you're right Libya
nope oh [__] I don't know Olivia's in
Africa okay I'm [__] too close stuff
Jordan and Israel guys Jordan and Israel
I was gonna say Israel yeah and uh and
they and and the money in the Red Dead
Sea is actually all the minerals crazy
minerals really yeah for skin and all
that the whole skincare product oh that
makes sense yeah to foliate your skin
yeah with the Dead Sea salt
guess what guess what animal they got in
Israel and in Jordan which I didn't know
what do you mean like on the loose yeah
what's they're not on a forced out there
no Eagles yeah got those
what is I guess right Eagle no there's
another what was the question what
animal does it walk on four four legs
sure does
carnivore coyote there's Bears they got
jackals is there bears we're talking
about bears
I don't think there are bears there may
be mountain lions something like uh
mountains no there were some leopards
but they got shot
back in the day some leopards yeah they
were leopards oh the leopard's the
answer nope
um Farmers see them all the time too in
the Golan Heights they're all over Cows
Farmers seal yeah kind of weird Mountain
Lights no
what is it for fun hyenas oh what I use
or African I know someone brought them
over there I was like and those are no
pumps are no go ahead and bring up a map
of the area please give me the area
again Jordan well the Middle East Israel
well that makes sense because the Middle
East they must have uh imported them in
right yeah now see do you see go go to
that go to that again the first one yeah
so you see where Egypt is Cairo that's
Egypt that's Africa that's north of
Africa oh I see it see how it's attached
to to what to Israel right
to the Sinai that area right there
bro I had no idea okay I had no idea
after was attached to Israel yeah it's a
it's a strategic part of the world oh
it's where we all come from though
that's right like where cairo's at we
all come from the pretty much well like
when I did that well actually I did 23
of me it's like yeah you're all from the
was it the e-read actually rivers to
East Africa actually if we go down now
if we go down here Kenya is where we we
think that human civilization existed
right so if you were to go down
so what's that c right there you know
what that c is that's the Red Sea Red
Sea the Red Sea okay now now come over
here now go up again go up please go up
I heard I heard Egypt's a little
dangerous
he just has the most Isis right now yeah
all of them are up there now do you see
what's what that sea is right there this
one of that that's the Mediterranean
that's the Mediterranean see that's the
Mediterranean what's that Cyprus like
Cyprus is supposed to be amazing Cypress
is split between what two countries it's
split between what two countries and
they fought a war over it turkey and
Greece
okay now there you go guys it's
important to know go back to that go
back pull that pull back again buddy
pull back yeah so serious you were
serious you see where that's where
Israel is where the red is
so Syria Israel is surrounded by Syria
Iraq Saudi Arabia Egypt tough people
Jordan okay and they all invaded that
country yet if you got hit on all sides
in 1948 and 19. you want to see some
badasses you see how Afghanistan
surrounded by Pakistan Iran that's why
they've always been in the middle of all
the wars Afghan yeah but no one can
conquer Afghanistan Afghanistan people
that conquered the afghanis with their
afghanis themselves yep there's
Kyrgyzstan Uzbekistan Tajikistan all
that area overrun by everybody that's
why a Dagestan is there that's why uh
you got guys like khabib who are so
[__] tough different different white
people I had a I had a my driver in uh
Dallas was from Afghanistan came here
two months ago he's saying all his
families back there and I was like oh is
it is it crazy in Afghanistan he's like
great what do you mean what crazy how I
go with like the Taliban runs and I goes
this is this is a good thing for us this
is a good thing they because they take
care of people and he goes the that
thing was he was saying the extremists
like Isis he's like they're bad he's
like they're they're most extreme and he
goes you got to remember Isis is enough
they're not afghanis he's like a lot of
them are Americans Europeans he's like
they're not yeah he was like they're not
afghanis he's like people confuse Isis
he was there not afghanis and he was
like very adamant he's like they're not
Afghani well remember there's a lot of
the Taliban now are actually educated uh
they tend to have they have cell phones
they have Internet it's like you're
saying it's a good thing
I don't know that's what he said he was
he was because they take care of people
they make sure we're fed in some ways in
comparison to what was there that's why
he's saying he's saying before and like
when America you know invaded stuff he
was like he was a nightmare he's like
there's constant fighting now that
talban runs it he's like things for my
mom is so much better wow he's like so
much better wow yeah
and then I go you got a girl or somebody
he goes no no I don't this American
thing they sleep with multiple people I
don't that's not no no no he goes my
mom's friend from Morocco she have uh
cousin we get married she come out here
next week yeah like wow [__] have you
ever met her goes no yeah when you go
when you go to Israel all you have to do
is this you see like Jews and Muslims
working together Christians you have
Arab Christians Arab Muslims working
together you have Arab Arab Muslims
working with Jewish uh people and same
businesses oh we're all family
bartenders are Muslim this waste staff
is Israeli yeah we all get together and
then just just ask them this just go you
guys ever marry each other though
the guy was a Christian Arab I go but do
Christian Arabs would your daughter ever
marry a Muslim Arabs no no so now in the
oldest where where Mary's where they
think Mary conceived received the
Immaculate Conception was impregnated by
a spirit and was born with Jesus Christ
sure they have her like I saw the steps
that they believe that they believe she
walked that she lived in her house I was
thinking about it uh yesterday we were
talking about it I was thinking about it
like obviously I make jokes and whatever
like if you believe that you make fun of
me for Ghost Adventures but that's been
pretty cool oh so cool like I was so
like foundations usually easily pushed
me into any religion any cold yeah yeah
but that's the foundation of Western
Civilization you're a Christian or not
just know that it doesn't matter that's
mythology or that truth depending on how
you look at it Mary her house they
believe was actually the mother of Jesus
of Nazareth I went to Nazareth where her
house was I saw like they still have her
[__] original house the steps nice
property in front oh no sir they built a
they built a huge church over it okay
and so they build this so for Catholics
because Mary for Catholics is everything
the mother of Jesus so mother Mary's who
you pray to so so listen so there it is
Bubba so you see those steps please take
a look right there
right that's her house when you look in
there that's where she lived it's kind
of weird that's not like kids that's
2000 years old very Games of Thrones it
is it's two thousand years old well so
when you look at that you go what the
[__] that's where she lived that's where
she conceived how protected is it is
there security ever yes but but here's
what's interesting about it it's that so
the the holiest church for any Catholic
and there are a billion 800 Catholics in
the world or something the holiest spot
in the world for a Catholic is that
church okay that I went to in where
Nazareth Jesus of Nazareth Nazareth so
gotta remember Nazareth isn't is a
hundred percent Arab Talent and it's
Muslim Arabs and it's Christian Arabs
but there are a lot of Muslims Arabs now
what the Muslims want to do
is because we were there and they were
like yeah we got to be careful there's
been some Strife I said between what he
goes well Christian Muslim Christian
Arabs and Muslim members what's it about
and go well the the holiest place for
all Catholics and Christians really is
where Mary received the Immaculate
Conception
um and uh that's where the church is
and um the Muslims want to build a
mosque right in front of it that's
taller than
the church yeah so you can understand
where they're like hey hey hey can you
move this mosque maybe a little bit over
there no fight to the death oh dude it's
it's it's a whole nothing's killed more
people than religion it's a whole isn't
it interesting yeah
I love the whole Middle East like the
the I can't escape the religion from
that when you're there you just can feel
it well I love the whole Middle East
like how loyal they are like the respect
the values the family values and that
when I was talking to that driver he's
like he's like I need to make money so I
go back home or I bring my mom out here
he goes you Americans you turn 16 you
say see you you don't take care of your
parents he goes no that's no no no this
is bad this is very bad because they've
taken care of you all your life and then
you just leave them he's like that's no
and in my in my who is it where I come
from we take it now it's on us I totally
agree with that but the old everywhere
in the world is like that except for
America that's why we have psychological
problems correct you don't have anything
Jordan would go broke a therapist even
in Israel would go broke so you know
what you don't see in Israel or Jordan
well I don't know about that but but you
know what you definitely don't see what
I didn't see any of gays no no no I like
that you're transgender oh black people
nope I don't know what I'm going with
this so what is the one thing you don't
see and when you go to that City what is
the one thing you want homeless oh I
know Yeezys not one homeless person no
Yeezys not one homeless person really
because they take care of each other not
an old person on the street never
interesting never because your extended
family will take care of you no matter
what and if you if you're too crazy you
go to a hospital but that's how it is in
most the world except for America
because even in England like even here
you know my mom born and raised in
England when they came here my aunt
lived with my grandma until she was 90.
like they all in my uncles everyone they
live in the same house so in Jordan uh
our guide he said when Jordan the way we
do it is this
I live on a family compound my sons stay
with us our family their wives they
marry move in with us and the family so
we they get a house right in the same
compound we all live in the same so when
he comes home he comes home to [__]
20 people that's great how beautiful so
cool and he said so every time I'm at
home all I hear is children playing oh
nothing better is there anything better
than that better but in America it's
like we want our independence so we want
to turn 16 18 yeah
it's a bummer right yeah for you and I
it is because you and I think that way
when I'm with when I see well of course
my kids to [__] live with me no no no
no no I know dude no no if I had my way
I'd have my ex-wife living with us yeah
that's weird women don't get along yeah
but I mean I would I'd be like everybody
move in the same compound if I I'd be
like I'm gonna buy a huge compound in
Texas we're all living together and
you'd move in there too and you'd be
[__] you'd get my water every morning
from the well I'll [__] your girls right
what what you know I'd be a liability
right don't [__] your girls right wait
wait my girls girls you talking about my
wives name it you you leave for work I'm
[__] girls right yeah I'm a liability
bro you know this Doug come on baby I'm
[__] right you leave [__]
my face and you're gonna know but you're
never gonna say anything you're gonna
know but you can't do anything about it
and you're like you're gonna look at
your ex Mike you're awfully cheerful
this morning oh yeah Brandon was uh
who's helping out with some stuff
take you to pound town baby eggs over
easy [__] right
I [__] find you hey here's the thing
eggs are easy two pieces of bacon [__]
right
you know the deal big Brown's in town
wow
I'm not doing that it's over easy so
wait hey
bye honey Brian's gone hey eggs over
easy two pieces of bacon on my dick
right that's every Monday right and
that's a Monday for your boy [__] you
girls you'll use their name leave out
the names
[__] girls I have my way right
because I'm a man I'm the man of the
house that's the police that's Joe Rogan
what
Joe Rogan call me let me talk I love him
all right we'll pause Brandon let's take
a little break let's take a little break
you're scared Jared's scared now now
I'll tell you what no matter whether
you're scared or not I'll tell you I'm
not scared of Covina this freaking
Thursday Friday Saturday I'm there
Covina yeah well don't be afraid of that
don't be afraid that's the new club it's
the new new you got to try it out but I
wish you were in town You Laugh Factory
yeah there's a little theater up there
oh in the heart of Covina all I know is
if you're gonna be in Denver in downtown
Denver anywhere near Denver you come to
Comedy Works this coming Thursday Friday
Saturday no just Friday Saturday says oh
no I'm sorry Thursday Friday Saturday I
got that confused comment it's Comedy
Works one of my favorite rooms in the
country it's the best green Greenville
South Carolina you're up next after that
blue room one of my favorite spots
briancallen.com Blue Room that's uh
that's now you know the boys like us man
people they want us to be the epitome of
Health gotta keep sharp but yeah we have
a little we have a little cheat code we
have on it we have on it.com f-a-t-k you
save 10 off everything including Alpha
Brain instant regular Alpha Brain Alpha
Brain Black Label which your boy uses
which I spit fire I spit fire Dylon
Dylon dalon Alpha Brain Focus shot Alpha
Brain pre-workout we got new mood total
gut health protein powders but they have
the number one nootropic on the plant
that sold over a million bottles money
back guarantee son if you don't love it
you don't have to return the Alpha Brain
keep it share it with a friend who
appreciated you ungrateful bastards but
you get your money back Alpha Brain
Black is what I take get you some right
now onit.com
f-a-t-k 10% off everything include an
Alpha Brain you're welcome that's right
I got nuts on nuts on nuts you look at
me right now you're like Brennan's the
richest guy in the world how does he
have all those macadamia nuts I thought
those were only for the rich the elite
they used to be and then my friends at
House of macadamias came along and they
sourced over 90 farms in South Africa to
bring you the tastiest macadamias on the
planet they're the best just we eat them
here non-freaking stop how do you think
Talon's Lids look so damn good his hair
not so much Lids popping daddy we got
the Macadamia snack bar which we love
here look at all these nuts these are
the house of macadamus dipped white
chocolate flavored the regular
chocolate's great I got the raspberry
vanilla chocolate over there I got the
bar the butter here we got all the nuts
in the world it's farmer owned that's
how they can give you quality freaking
macadamia nuts at the price point that
you deserve House of macadamia's range
of products from hand sorted nuts like
these and the chocolate covered all
right they have all natural flavors even
dipped in sugar-free chocolate macadamia
bars I get the bars in my hand right
here all right 45 macadamia nuts are in
the bars they get the creamy Nut Butter
nut butter for your mouth is right here
the cold press extra virgin Macadamia
Oil all right they got it all they also
never do discounts they're already a
fair price but they're gonna do it just
for the fire and get army that's right
and for a limit time my friend that
house on macadamians are giving you a
free box of 45 Macadamia snack bars you
get the variety pack these are the
coconut white chocolate which is my
favorite it might not be yours so you
get the variety pack pick which one you
love and then order the Box save 20 off
go to houseomeacademias.com tfak for all
the nuts the chocolate dipped the salt
in the house of macadamia snack bars the
variety pack the butter is 20 off house
macadamias.com DFA K now let's get back
to the program you nut lovers how famous
is Joe Rogan oh by the way my friend who
just called me I'm in I'm in Israel
there's an Ethiopian Jew he Fades
Ethiopian and he's Jewish he was he had
Khan from Ethiopia to Ethiopia is in
what country Africa Egypt God damn it
dude I suck at geography Ethiopia though
Ethiopians
Africa continent of Africa it's its own
yeah so that's where uh freaking arsema
yes around that area yes he looks at me
like a return I mean I I need you to
educate someone I know I know look to me
and he goes do you come out on Joe Rogan
I'm like holy [__] an Ethiopian Jew in
Israel listens to Joe Rogan yeah man
I mean he's taught it has to be top ten
how he's gonna time people of the year
he could easily should be up for a
debate taught people agree 100 oh the
[__] he's doing Robert F Kennedy said
you and I haven't talked about the RFK
stuff oh man that was damn bro how long
how long have I been trying to put you
on RFK wow how long have I been trying
to go on our RFK and he's running as a
Democrat brand you know I know him a
little bit right he hired me to do stand
up uh because he was at a show of mine
and he walked out to me after I did
really well and he goes can you do that
can you do that in New York I said yeah
can I
he's such a good guy man his kids are
great
um did you see that video I posted I
said our our RFK is jacked jacked bro
Well Jack he's saucing obviously uh he's
on trt you gotta be careful with saucin
just trt is now trt is different yeah
um I'm I'm
um but what do you think about that like
for me I listened to it and I went
if you're litigating a case you got to
know everything about that case right
he's a big [__] boy dude come on how
old is how old is he here's my thing do
you want to listen to Biden and the
Crypt Keepers or do you want to listen
to this guy and Joe Rogan how old is
Robert F Kennedy I'll look it up right
after this I think he's 70. I think he's
70. I like how people are like it's only
135 on the bar and my cares look at this
[__] he's in what are you talking about
yeah sure show Biden incline benching
pop up
you can't even walk upstairs
came ride a bike look at this [__]
guy I mean you gotta love that workout
in jeans [__] gangster
God I'm gonna work out in jeans from now
on 69. he's incredible
so when I met him his voice I wonder
what they're gonna do uh
I wonder what the Democrats gonna do
because a they don't want him to win
right because he's going to get in there
and cause a storm
he probably won't win Bubba but I think
even him running put shed some light on
a lot of things like it's gonna be tough
for him to win you know he's in the in
the polls he's up over biting right now
after doing Rogan well he's he's hard to
ignore I mean that that here's where it
gets dicey
he is voicing me tough for some people
if they're stupid about it but who cares
about their voice look at buying them
for God's sakes
yeah at least this guy can talk and he
speaks in full sentences and knows what
the [__] he's talking about where it
gets dicey for him is and he doesn't
want to run on anti-vaxx he didn't want
to talk about vaccines but Rogan brought
up he's like all right let's do this
even when he went on breaking points
he's like I don't be the vaccine craze
that's not what I'm about man but when
people bring up he's like all right if
you want to go down that route I'm gonna
light you up so when they bring it up
he's like yep where it gets dicey for
him which a lot of the Democrats and the
right are going to focus on is when he
starts talking about Wi-Fi causing
cancer that stuff to prove then also the
frogs you know with the with the water
real tough it again I don't know any of
that stuff but it's just I know from a
consumer people oh he's crazy so he
needs to back off a little bit of that
stuff the problem is what if he's right
you know what I'm saying but they're
gonna Mark him as crazy oh he's a crazy
conspiracy yeah man the the data that he
has on vaccines here's my baby girl
coming December yeah not a
[__] chance they're gonna vaccinate
my kid not a chance not a chance well
let me let me
posit a question to you is it possible
though that the people that are in the
weeds of vaccines that develop them that
are responsible for them the scientists
no details that none of us know and they
just
haven't
articulated them yet no see but but this
this is where we gotta be careful with
RFK going oh he's a crazy anti-vaccine
he's not anti-vaccine he's anti-covet
vaccine because you know he's he's no no
he's well we'll talk about vaccine
injury for sure in the amount of deaths
that have come from vaccines when the
amount of deaths before that it is his
it is his in
conclusion
autism uh he said that the idea that
there is an Evidence linking it is is a
fallacy said because ethyl Mercury they
think might go into the brain because
you don't see it in the bloodstream is
it goes through the blood-brain barrier
now is there the now what you have to
know is most vaccines don't have ethyl
Mercure anymore but they do have
aluminum now how much aluminum a lot of
them do have mercury they'll be a lot of
them still do well there's flu shot and
then yeah but then look how many
vaccines we have now compared to even
when I was getting well that's your
question so so it used to be no first I
got six we've got six vaccines now you
get 71 vaccines correct by the time
they're four so so I would say that
Hepatitis B what are we doing yeah is it
fair to say that because there's so much
money in vaccines well that's that's
clear yeah
it's clear that's where I go
um there's a business behind it and then
people can take advantage of that stuff
and then it's it's the Public's job and
people like RFK go hold on here hold on
all right the gig's up the not all
vaccines shouldn't be we shouldn't get
rid of all of them but come on 70 for
four-year-old what are you doing here
how much money do you guys need well one
day old you know sometimes you get a lot
I don't say that they're like kids are
getting vaccinated when they're an hour
old in some cases well be now when your
baby comes the first thing they do is
put a vaccine in it yeah now that might
save lives I don't know I'm not a doctor
so I'm not either I'm really careful
about saying it's gonna surprise a lot
of people neither so doctors which is
surprising but what's the thing is when
people go you're not an expert what do
you know well I do know I can't trust
the experts because there's there's
certain agendas that are behind this and
there's a money Trail there so do I do
know the odds are my baby will be
completely healthy with knocking the
vaccine I know there there is a risk
involved if that baby is vaccinated I
know one in 35 kids have autism when
years and years ago that was not the
case now can you chalk that up just the
vaccines I don't think so right but
let's say it is a factor Brian it's okay
for me to go you know what I'm gonna
wait till I know more before you stick
that needle on my son that's where my
kids and then what I shouldn't do I
shouldn't be disciplined by my school
yeah because everyone's in on it and I
and listen I don't think doctors and
pediatricians are bad people I think
that a product of the system and for all
they know they are good but they don't
know they don't look into it your
general doctor they don't look into it
they go yeah I get a push back when I
push this vaccine we haven't had any
issues with it they say it's good
they're not doing the research nobody's
an expert so so what I'd like we got to
be careful with the term expert too
because even that Dr moats were the
Peter moats whatever yeah that Peter guy
yes he he does vaccines if you go down
the trail of the vaccine that he's
pushing the things that he said
especially in covid he's more wrong than
he is right not even close Oh you mean
uh Peter Peter Hotes Peter he's if you
look up just facts he's more wrong about
this code thing than he is I mean nine
times a ten he's dead wrong on this [__]
now people say oh we just don't know
that's fine but what I would need is for
him to accountability that's my issue
when he keeps doubling down so he keeps
doubling down on everything and you have
no remorse
and when you go well 200 on vaccinated
people died
well where did you get that stat how do
you know they're unvaccinated so I would
say how do we know they wouldn't have
died if they got vaccinated I would say
this
um I think that I interviewed that guy
Paul offit that Robert F Kennedy was
talking about when he said the blood
bearing but they found the hidden
monkeys yeah quiet on the phone
um I I would say that I would like the
medical experts the establishment
to really come out and articulate for us
as the public in the face I'd like a
rebuttal to uh Robert Kennedy Jr and
that's why that's why president was
trying but that's what Brooklyn's trying
to do but this is what they always do
when any anytime there's an outlet
that's going against the grain they go
he's crazy don't listen to him
he's crazy he's an outlet he's [__]
about you crazy we can't even entertain
this we know he's not crazy we know he's
a very educated smart guy and look at
what he's done and the cases that he's
won against the vaccines he's won a ton
of [__] cases yeah a ton yeah so we
know that he has he's qualifying that
background what America what Americans
need is transparency if RFK goes on
there if he's so batshit crazy put your
best person against him and light him up
and then the rest of us who aren't RFK
side go he is a little crazy yeah I feel
like as a scientist if I really was
doing this I'd be chomping at the bit to
go out but remember scientists aren't
the most they're not the most articulate
when it comes to speech they're very
smart here but when it comes to
expressing it the lawyers used to making
a case correct they don't have to talk
for a living RFK can talk his ass off
but that guy Peter he talks he put on
Good Morning America been on CNN every
[__] week so what are you so scared
of well are you scared that he was
afraid because it is a fight and he said
on Rogan he goes no man he's really
clever I don't want to get caught up in
that it's like you're a [__] but that's
the problem with these people you're
[__] [__]
debate well I would say what's the same
thing no hold on it's the same thing
with the Democrats same thing with the
Democrats go we're not even in debate
we're not We're Not Gonna Take the part
in the debates
because you because you're going to lose
that's not American dudes are you
kidding me yeah you're not eating up for
a debate right you're just gonna forgo
the debate that's not American at all
right and with this guy if you're so
confident let's have a dialogue and and
this is where people are gonna twist it
you assume Rogan's all in on RFK you
don't know Rogan Rogan's gonna go on
there and he's going to be the mediator
he's gonna be the guy there the
moderator and he's not gonna jump down
Peter's throat I guarantee you if Peter
goes on there and disproves all the [__]
rfk's talking about runes go Peter's
right man we were completely wrong
people don't know Rogan people rooms and
get on their billion oh my God you don't
know Rogan Rogan's gonna go on there and
give everybody a fair shake and whoever
comes out on top that's what's gonna
happen truth truth that's all he gives a
[__] about but how crazy and they're
trying to do something he said oh dude
he's gonna bully him he's gonna vilify
him no because that's what you guys do
well when he read he said I read the
real Anthony Falcon he goes if even half
of it is a lie I can't believe you had
been sued have you read that book no
have you yes
I gotta read it I got a copy I get a
signed copy I gotta read it it's insane
dude when you go down the the path with
when when he was involved with the aid
stuff it will make you disgusted with
this man
again if even half of it is true what
the [__] are we doing man well the fact
that he hasn't been sued for defamation
would mean isn't that weird would mean
you know it's interesting but you do you
then I'm staying quiet about it because
I don't know enough that's the problem
we shouldn't stay quiet I'm not staying
quiet because when you stay quiet we're
going to continue down this cycle and
that's the definition of craziness no no
we're going down this uh but I think I
think I'm quiet because I don't know
anything I just think that I'd like to
see the medical establishment debate and
what I'm saying be is don't be quiet on
saying hey debate I don't know either
that's what I mean I'm not an expert I
want to see but I would love to see this
guy an expert debate once you guys stop
what's the problem yes why are we scared
of a debate there's nothing more
American than that that's also how you
get the best ideas yeah what are we
doing and you're so scared you can't
debate what are you hiding
because one guy's like fully down for it
the other guy no no way because he's
gonna compromise he's done some
compromising [__]
I hope you guys learned a lot today
I really do
Red Sea and Dead Sea are different yeah
what do you got Jen
alrighty
by the way just letting you know the
current events are not that great
go to the polls for uh RFK and Biden in
the Democrats yep
I'm liking your passion
you should be 2024 is going to be a big
deal
um who want to continue the same chaos
go ahead don't vote stay quiet I agree
with that buddy [__] June 19. let's
see who you why am I a [__] now hey why
is this hey like girls right no way nice
Daddy's Daddy's here right you leave
daddy here
hey eggs over easy very good go to work
I'll fight you bro yeah yeah you try you
can't do anything all right it's
frustrating right
and you'll know him be there when you're
asleep when you're taking a nap and I
jump on you and throw you in a headlock
it still does nothing but here's the
thing it's so frustrating and also messy
I'm messy you know I'll be there I'm not
cleaning up are you gonna are you gonna
Brendan please play wait no are those
just draws on my face yeah and then you
might push some [__] over us for spite
hey did Brendan leave his shoes yes
it'll be back tomorrow you're gonna push
my toothbrush over it this is my salon
King
and I gotta I got a picture of me and
you just turn it over one of their
protein drinks in the fridge oh Brent
said you'll be back tomorrow he likes
them after you get his dick size you're
a [__] staying on my [__] on my match
yeah Brent said he likes to his dick
sucked I'm doing a protein drink and
blow up our toilet it's really annoying
I can't no we can't see that there's a
flag in your [__] says Brendan was here
I mean you can't stop him from coming
either he just walks in like Kramer
and gets his dick out and says go to
work ladies uh what is this
um this right here so this is from June
19th though and this is uh no June 19th
won't work yeah oh no oh no June 19th
I'm sorry I thought you said January
wow so it said last Wednesday The
Economist in Yugo have released a survey
showing that Kennedy with the highest
favorability rating
which is good of all current 2024
president candidates 49 of respondents
said that they saw him favorably and 30
percent viewed he could take votes away
from Biden that's what they're worried
about and then Trump wins well and then
the the do You Hear the recording on
Trump came out about the hidden files
yeah all Tim saying he doesn't really
want to go to war there's nothing there
but they're keeping the news cycle to
suppress this biting stuff even more
figure it out everybody what else you
got Jen so that that's that's part of it
right here bombshell audio recording
Have you listened to it I listened to it
it's so stupid so this is the the meat
of it here right
except it is like highly confidential
secret there's a secret information look
at this you attack and Hillary would
print that out all the time you know
by the way is that incredible yeah I was
just saying because we're talking about
it and you know he said he wanted to
attack Iran
this was done by the military given to
me
um I think we can probably yeah
we'll have to see yeah
see this President I could have did last
year no I can't you know but this is
yeah
is that interesting that's a problem
that's so cool he also said before this
though hold on it's by the doj or
something
all sorts of
pages
who was recording this I don't know
that's a good I mean people that hate
him
he said I just found out this isn't
isn't this amazing it's like highly
confidential it's gonna be it's gonna
give me some hot water
you see he's
um
that's not good they're doing everything
they can to make sure he can't run yeah
yeah that's right
hold on there's an important part here
he said there was the defense department
what's that he said it was the the
defense department that will the whole
Iran thing was the defense department
not him yes so I mean we all know like
when you get into like presidency
you're not really in control it's
everyone around you that's in control
right yeah you're a puppet master
I don't know I don't know enough about
this but that's that's what I saw
well he said Millie
anyways oh yeah I'm not educated in this
so I don't want to say anything
alrighty
so apparently a fan threw their mother's
ashes at pink
during one of the concerts on stage and
she was actually pretty cool about it I
thought she was like yeah it's a little
over the top right it was she stopped
for a moment but wait what's your take
on let me see come on let me see this
[Music]
she goes I don't know how I feel about
this
[Music]
and then she went back to singing
like a pro
she insane man she's one of the best
scene her and Christina Aguilera were
the best singers she and sing sing yeah
those are some interesting legs too
she's got she's been training she's
bodied up you're seeing her do all these
flips on the thing I saw on Twitter
someone goes there's no need for this at
a pink concert she's going
to tied up to some like strings she's
going the guy goes she knows damn well
they don't need this in this concert
just doing like a thousand flips like
what song does this go to
yeah she's bodied up yeah
um uh what's your take on um oh God
Meghan Markle and Prince Harry oh
dude you give us [__] Prince Harry
and you guys get Johnny Depp can we
trade back like John Depp lives in
England now Prince Harry's here is there
a bigger cut than Prince Harry what a
piece of [__] dude oh are you're leaving
the royal family you piece of [__] are
you kidding me dude well he goes bad on
him they just turned out not to be that
interesting right so their podcast well
on Spotify Spotify stop listening we're
good and then Meghan Markle who nobody
can stand she couldn't book any gas
should I book in um uh Jin's girl uh my
girl what's her name Taylor Swift and
she was like I'm good really no but no
one wants to be associated with it dude
you know her we know that people in L.A
know she was
very promiscuous I don't know yeah we
know this you know I don't know yeah we
know this I mean she was she and she she
was oh I was oh I can't believe I was
you remember she was on uh Howie
Mandel's game show where she held the
case you know I was sexualized
well you were hot as [__] so she's all
right she's all right she's all right
she's all right she also had a career
it's like don't act like you had a I
mean you you didn't really have
Hollywood she did all right she married
a prince she's beautiful I think she's
beautiful but no she's pretty obviously
gorgeous
talk about [__] up a guy's life women
can be the death of she literally was
like carry your family's evil and we
need to get out well they say a
narcissist will separate you from
everyone you know the first thing they
do is they do everything they can to
separate you from all your friends she
ostracized him from the royal family you
know they don't allow her in the in the
Royal yeah because she made up a bunch
of [__] there's a few reasons why
she's not allowed there the thing of
Harry the brother William's like what
the [__] are you doing dude I mean
that's pretty good brother you know what
your brother goes astray and you're like
they don't talk to you anymore the house
I'm [__] him they don't talk anymore
or the house of Windsor yeah the house
of Windsor has been standing for a
thousand years they didn't invite her
when the the new King Arthur where the
[__] they're like we're good yeah yeah
and if it turns out they don't have a
skill set that people are interested in
your perspective is no good here we all
live regular lives so you're not
interesting you're not that talented
well all they are is the Kardashians of
England that's all they are well I think
Prince Harry I think he served 10 years
in the military and actually did combat
I he was a dude man and well you know
not a bad guy uh but you know but like
you said he got caught up with this girl
he's a definition of a cut well you get
a hot girl and she pulls you from the
royal family that's a problem and then
he's like we don't know what we're gonna
do in our house in Montecito the 40
million dollar home I don't we're so
lost we lost Spotify deal he's such a
cut is that what he said yeah yeah and
then with South Park just making fun
they tried Sue in South Park good luck
with that
you can't make fun of us wait so hey
dumbass you're not in the royal family
remember you left
I don't know if this you don't know a
lot today dude hey man I don't know I
don't know what's going on since you've
been back from Korea you don't know
anything what's great is that the real
chin that's the real chin oh [__]
he's a [__] though he's a mascot of
[__] any redhead you have dare you what
if he moves into a redhead what what if
he moves into our concert girl
dude you can't just use your weight I'd
be like Harry don't you have to go to
work you're just gonna watch
are you jacking off in the corner do you
have red hair it bothers me if Kay
wanted to come on the show will we have
him of course
he's actually I I
spent just one a couple two days with
him and I really like them yeah so he
did serve the military and she was an
actress with a popular show so I saw the
Netflix I'm gonna be honest full
disclosure when I saw them thing about
him I I liked him right anyway before
but I liked her I I had a very
sympathetic point of view now they're
all cucks and also they're like they're
like we don't we're sick of the media
leave us alone buy our best [__] buy
our book listen to me on Spotify check
out my show on Netflix please leave us
alone we don't want to fame she's also
known to Stage Paparazzi yeah she's a
star she tells people she's a group
she's a groupie and bagged the dumbass
redhead the weak link of the royal
family God figure it out dude he's a
[__] he's going you're going so hard on
it the English can't stand him by the
way they're mad at him because he went
bad on them mad can't go back dude he
left the royal family and moved to
Montecito California you can't do it and
then all they do is talk [__] about
America go back to England you [__]
redhead we're all set on redheads here
dude she taught him about systemic
racism it's like you listen oh [__] oh
she experience racism her whole family's
like we're sorry she's a terrible human
being the dad was like I haven't talked
to her in years really yeah she's an
awful person
hmm
I don't know any all right I'd give her
a shot yeah
uh so what do you guys think about this
so Netflix announced that
uh
it's like one of the biggest news I mean
I just mean it's like so after the Titan
you know the whole implosion thing with
the submarine uh Netflix did announce
that they're gonna have Titanic back on
Netflix because it's current I don't
give a [__] yeah so I don't know do you
guys think it's like it's a little
insensitive I guess like you they could
wait a little bit but this trying to
capitalize on the fame but they are also
but also remember why is this such a
narrative why is such a story would have
been a big story why is such a big story
because of the White House they wanted
to they wanted to suppress 100 biting
information so they release all this
press it gets all the Press so Netflix
like we didn't do it we're just gonna
capitalize on the corrupt system
so there was don't be mad at Netflix so
this happened too I also saw this that
during the coverage that the USDA
allowed the sale of uh lab-grown meat to
the U.S that's impressive
so that's the future everybody a little
bit of chicken's gonna be factory made
it's not a bad thing is it I wonder if
you can taste the difference if it's as
long as it's like in 10 in 20 years
that's going to be probably what all is
all this healthy then yeah that's fine
it's better for the environment blah
blah yeah that will happen to be on me
remember that whole craze it's they're
dying are they yeah I think in this
article it's so unhealthy for you yeah
it has all those all that [__] in it
so unhealthy for you
wow good meat
alrighty wow
wow oh this one I thought was crazy so a
woman
I think it was in San Antonio somewhere
in Texas she thought she was being
kidnapped by her Uber driver to go to
Mexico like as a part of a cartel so she
pulled out her gun and shot him in the
head and he died
and she's charged with murder right now
but was he taking her no he's just an
Uber driver and I guess so he's like you
put in the address she saw traffic signs
that said Juarez Mexico so she freaked
out she never been to Texas I don't know
so it must have been close to El Paso I
assume yeah to Juarez let me see here
let me see her yeah I'll pass it
I wonder if she was like super like is
she a sniper or something
she's sniper hi because one eye bigger
than the other right you sniper oh my
goodness earned Jeff basil you snipers
huh
and Jeff Bay is a girl got that
chameleon eye wonky eye right all the
money in the world can't fix it Daddy
ready Brandon I'm not gonna be involved
you guys are [__] they can't fix that
though one eye big guy
when you're when you're a kid you can no
no there's a fighter there's a fighter
in the UFC who had it yeah I know I know
you're talking about the daddy standing
cat no he looks like Nick Davis
no he's not he was he was trained by a
frost a hobby I don't know I'll give you
his name later but but he had a while
yeah I'd walk and then he had it fixed
it's it's I think it's like the muscles
in the eye right something yeah it's
something that's not too hard to fix I
guess but yeah so you're right uh South
Central El Paso
she thought he was taking her she looks
devastated she should have put it in her
Maps she's not smart that's why I think
she was under the influence of something
yeah and freaked out you know she's just
she looks crazy she was going to see her
boyfriend we would drive to go to see
her boyfriend dude this happened
did her boyfriend live in Juarez no
apparently not that is so crazy dude did
she talk to the cat the Uber he's like
there's no no I no I'm driving to where
you put in [__] we're also in El Paso
Texas so there's signs for a Mexican
take me to my destination or just drop
me off here instead of just shooting
randomly in the head I feel like there
might have been a language barrier where
they couldn't communicate and that's
right yeah no he's yeah okay this is
it's probably true yeah this is a dude
that's over Daniel yeah
he is a kidnapper but no he's not that
sucks yes he's the only guy that
provided for his family that's a bummer
you meet one crazy lady yeah what a
bummer man it's terrible what a bummer
all right let's go to I feel bad for
that family oh I don't know if you guys
care about this but the first malaria
cases in 20 years popped up in Texas and
Florida
well what is Hunter Schaefer's ethereal
Oscar off that I was don't go to that
why I want to make sure everything's all
right why is it's a feather it's a
transgender brain yeah oh that is yeah
you're gay no yeah it is yeah from
Euphoria transgender I'm not mad at it
beautifully does it look like Machine
Gun Kelly sure whatever oh that's a
transgender person yeah you're just
figuring that out I'm mad at it that's
Georgie's favorite character a little
bit in Euphoria really she's good on you
good in you foreign
a little bit attracted to that
that's a girl I would make out with her
him yeah him I don't know her I would
kiss him super hard yeah we know this
would you no [__] liar I mean we'll
see maybe yeah if you guys are red if
you're around if you're around that
person for long enough you're you're
gonna be like damn if we hit it off girl
I don't see color dude she's all skinny
and you already did it bro look at her
shoulders you already made it out you've
already made out with a [__] I know
damn it in that outfit she's hanging
around
but you didn't always have those giant
titties not in Euphoria no those are
definitely fake for sure oh are they gin
why because it's a man no not just that
man if you take hormones you still grow
like no no no no no those are no trash
are obviously fake doesn't that show you
man don't you just love women like I see
that that's a female form and I'm just
like I'm in go for it look at the waist
this one we saw earlier this is a
um so this is this chimp named vanilla
apparently was in a cage for her entire
life and finally saw the sunlight this
is a good metaphor for Brendan's
political life and this is also like a
chimp that was used for Laboratories
this is Brandon after we started reading
watch
boxes they started reading and seeing
that the world is
and that's it that's the alpha chimp
look oh it's like damn check out the sun
look at the alpha chimp just hugged her
yeah he's hugged her he's like check
this out man
it's walking around I love how they're
all friends their [__] are
disgusting that's her [__] vagina sorry
now he was in a lab his whole life she
she was in a lab her whole life and then
he just let her out yeah
now they can put her back in the lab
that's even more fun no no this is a
sanctuary for these chimps that used to
be in Labs you know they keep animals
that smart enough it sucks but you know
I was telling Brian too like we need
this to happen I would let them live
there though when they're not there yes
let them have the Sun and all that stuff
see that's how they get you chin you're
like well we need to do this to help us
we need the testing we do
for medicine never had never been
outside of five foot square cage you
think that's right that's [__] up a
garage sale which was closed in 1987
until she was two first two years she
was chilling out that's that's so gross
yeah but there's that's the first image
of her looking at the sky for the first
time burn those eyes stare at the sun
too long hey everybody a lot of work can
you hear some jumps around in this
because Brennan's awesome my mom wants
to we're back now and then okay so
we're actually one hour and 24 minutes
in so here's the last one I want to show
you guys I think this is good for all of
us to watch I saw this recently oh I
don't know if you guys seen this
this is uh Roy Jones Jr talking to
another Boxer a young boxer
see I like this how your power gave you
more
when there's more given more as expected
you understand that but there's some
pressure though I understand the
pressure but God built us different do
you just tell me that you know I'm 23 so
sometimes it's the biggest 23 year old
I've ever seen but it's pretty much
because we're the ones that can take it
Jeremy I think he can sometime Jeremy
get messed up sometime but Jared can
wear these shoes that's why Jared has it
too bad Jared has a destiny that Jared
can't run from
and Jerry they know coward always know
that
right
so Jared mess with making his mind
and let's go you gotta ride that horse
son I'm sorry you got to ride that horse
I brought it you ain't got a brother say
Wheels come off but you gotta ride it
you understand me you got a relative you
get where you want to be in life then
you can get off of it but we're gonna
ride that horse that's just what we got
to do huh that's [__] great dude my
man I don't think that guy wants to
fight that's great that's what I'm
thinking he's all Jared don't want to
fight uh right but um I love that I love
Jared terrified it's a great message
Jared terrified to fight no I know but
you gotta fight jir don't want to fight
I know but you gotta get on that horse I
don't want me on a horse I know but
Jared I just said is terrified the movie
the movie is he fights and wins but the
reality
Jared can do many other things it's a
coach is the other coach who's like this
the other coach is like hey Roy I love
the speech he doesn't have it he doesn't
have it man he has no heart
uh Jared has many other hands in
business and can make a lot of money not
getting punched in the head do you know
how many times I saw an acting teacher
give an actor that that speech you got
it you gotta assume the responsibility
do you know how many of those actors
came through so Jared right now is 14-0
14 Kos so he's meant to be this guy he's
big baby let me see him what way is he
fighting Jared need to get a [__]
together I don't know what a weighty is
but his big kid I barely just saw this
thing so I don't know he looks like a
cruiser away probably he's much taller
than Chicago
is very small
hold on Jared don't want to do this not
something you're gonna do it you're
gonna ride that horse
you keep talking about horses dude I
don't even [__] with horses oh he's six
four
he's a big phone oh he's heavyweight
there you go Jared a heavyweight 78 inch
reach that's more than Jones right no it
turns 84 right Jones uh 84. something
like that
he's stud and he's 23 years old
[Music]
he's meant for it though maybe he's
having a hard day shout out Jared I know
how that goes dude
Brendan don't want to do this right now
all right
yeah I know you don't but you gotta
taste it podcasting of money you were
like I know you don't want to do the
worst thing that happened to your
fighter was meeting me because you're
running oh it's the best thing I know I
know you realize Brendan sure as [__]
didn't want to do this I want to hang
and have dinner and [__] [__]
silly
how many times when you felt like I
don't want to do this [__] and you had
to fight that you won versus well he was
a maniac he was he trained so hard but
but how many times when you felt like I
don't want to do this but you actually
won versus lost
uh every time you won when Roblox no
when Rogan saw it 50 50. sometimes when
you saw the light at the end of the
tunnel and you were like I want to get
the [__] out of this prison Center yeah
Jared don't want to do that
was going to fight uh Jared has a long
road yeah it could be crazy get the
weigh-ins he's gonna fight Travis Brown
how you feeling he goes
so that's one of the times
he goes I go how you doing he goes he
goes dead serious he goes I'm terrified
of course dude he's like I don't think
he's gonna go well dude trash Brown is
like freaking monster and he gets out
there and like fatigue is taking over
he's like hey look I just woke up from a
nap
sleeping in the back I was like hey man
this doesn't how about when Tim Tebow
was fighting Arlovski comes in the
locker room he's like you ready to go
she's like what's wrong I was like I
started crying he's all
I said Jared don't want to do this
there's no Roy Jones to pump me up that
should be the title Jared don't want to
be so funny dude because I see like it
was Frankie Edgar and Jose Aldo two guys
game bread [__] game bread just
don't want to do this
it was hard to talk I was so scared
so scared if I know where Andrews like
you know Andrew a Russian monster I mean
I remember Tim was like hold on I
thought all you guys were like excited
back I'm like oh no no you kind of want
that fight dude I should split decision
I won that fight but still Tim T was
like oh I figured the locker rooms were
different I thought it was like a
football lock I'm like no no no don't
don't come back here yeah
he said you'd be all right I'm like you
think he's like I don't know I'm like
could you pray for me
hey Eric he's gonna listen to you
all right let's get out of here hey
Denver I'll see you this weekend come
see me this weekend Denver let's go
Comedy Works my mom had hip surgery I
think she's still gonna come to the show
I hope so I got tickets for her Denver
tickets
um it's gonna be fun I got him I got him
June 29 June 30 July 1. I got comedies
on the following weekend let's go Covina
Thursday Friday Saturday uh one show
Thursday two shows Friday two shows
Saturday get some it's a new laugh
factor in Covina come get you some Jared
scared cheers God bless everybody love
you guys Jared scared